[Music]
in cultural appropriation news submitted
by I was gonna marry David but she got a
girl she got a cup okay trying to say
lesbian yeah that makes sense
a white girl wearing a Chinese dress to
prom sparks a massive oh wait what the
[ __ ] lesbians are nasty I'm just saying
people that want to [ __ ] David is nasty
we went to a broad insult to a very
directive he fixed it you saying that
David's a lesbian and then Joe's like
that's nasty and I'm like what's messy
she clarify and then he's like no not
the lesbian thing that I love lesbians
[ __ ] David everyone knows jobs less
lesbians you know they're awesome even
the ones that play softball and look
look like my home you got out of the
hall they just jump right back a white
girl wearing a Chinese dress to prom
sparks a massive cultural appropriation
debate on Twitter never heard of
something that I like so we're also
gonna get a $10 prom dress I keep I
think it's sad you didn't even go viral
chip dress Tiffany wife give a [ __ ]
about Tiffany how dare you wear a
[ __ ] Chinese [ __ ] dress do you
have a tea ceremony for your wedding how
dare I honor my husband's culture how
dare you what that I you can wear one of
those dresses do you [ __ ] [ __ ]
appropriator I know right well write
your [ __ ] wedding I mean let's be
real though your husband's culture is
like Bermuda shorts and fanny packs and
white people you know Dallas Texas all
right so this girl here her name is
Keisha I believe is how you pronounce it
so Kenya tweeted this she's a white girl
with the black girl's name - what the
[ __ ] yeah she tweeted up prom and then B
photos sounds like some Old Testament
name Kezia this is Hugh it's gray yeah
you could color on it it looks great on
earth this is mainly what like made her
or like that people are holding on to
that she's appropriate all the time
that's bait nation moji - yeah that's
blast that's [ __ ] blast this is yeah
this is anglo-saxon this is [ __ ] is
why desaad there's no Asian person doing
this [ __ ] well no no no people that
don't know h3 h3 they that's vapenation
vapenation and then they do this pose in
a lot of their pictures because what
it's mocking is the Blessed [ __ ]
Instagram well I'm so blessed in the
[ __ ] hip-hop [ __ ] right but they see
that and they they don't even know what
this is they don't they overlook that
what they see is they go oh that's that
Thai greeting
I thought they had cold hands why people
do this how a couple years ago there was
a funny meme where this guy went to like
a Magic the Gathering
and he went to behind the chairs of
everybody while they're sitting there
and you could see their ass cracks and
he got on one knee and went like just a
camera like same [ __ ] like yeah blast
thing and it went it went viral
everywhere it wasn't like an
appropriation thing yeah but she's
wearing the dress and she's doing the
things that she's a part bringing that's
sort of like people see so is this lady
oh she's doing it - why yeah all these
girls are doing the blast
did the FBI talk to her like why were
you [ __ ] doing the thing I'm not
telling you [ __ ] we get the
interrogation like a [ __ ] flash on
your face right grab the back of her
head I tell you what Danny Hilaire yeah
would you recently real quick yeah
I know what does that say why don't you
read it any time [ __ ] spit in your
mouth or teeth up yes the been this good
Jeremy Lamb tweeted my culture is not
your goddamn prom dress better not use
the word god dude you better say Buddha
[ __ ] Jeremy at dude I want to see where
Jamie lives I want to see what Jeremy
has in his house first person that got
outraged yeah this is what he made it
viral I responded to this [ __ ] I
want to tell them the f-word so bad what
if she was just like no your culture is
my prom dress I'm wearing wearing your
culture understand this article here I'm
sorry Joe that ain't use your tweet they
use Gina and even a J's what the [ __ ]
did I wrote am I the only Asian person
that's not offended by this and people
are saying her namaste pose is racist
I'm pretty sure that's the pray hands
post they all been doing since the early
2000 then she does this whole thread and
how she explains further explains how
she's not offended yeah mine was not
that nice
and then AG rights I'm with you on this
it's not like she's out there
appropriating and making money off the
culture it's when someone like Katy
Perry does this [ __ ] in her music videos
that got me annoying at times at times
see they should have put my comment mine
was way more articulate than what did
you say all these people to [ __ ] this is
some [ __ ] bull you can't even find
your own tweet how the [ __ ] are they it
was days ago all right here we go all
right check this out how the [ __ ]
editor's put that [ __ ] in there alright
alright this is the kind of weak-minded
Asian activism that makes us look stupid
when we complain over pointless [ __ ]
fight for real things that matter when
your lives are threatened resources are
taken away and opportunities are
non-existent focus on becoming a
powerful individual that's my [ __ ]
twin like that one yeah that's a good
tweet sorry I didn't include in this you
better find my way blue who won - I like
that what I give you
so long I think it's always the white
the white people though like this is
probably the whitest Asian ever like
he's probably two percent Asian 98% um
say like I [ __ ] [ __ ] Nicki enough
times we're microbially I have for Asia
on my dick and body then probably this
guy so he tweeted you looked great Kezia
thank you for appreciating and not
appropriating a culture for an important
life event
she had zero ideas she was about to get
that hate from thousands of people over
it no need to call someone lazy when
they're trying to enjoy prom and look
pretty just because they didn't address
a racial issue is enough to recognize
she may have not understood it either
originally she's getting so many support
so much support from influential Asians
too that it's like it backfired on the
Jimmy Jeremy or the [ __ ] Jeremy laugh
because I'm like man there's no way we
can frame this that looks good a grown
agen man bullying a [ __ ] high school
girl yeah a man standing up because he
got offended by a high school girl and
even if she was even if this was racist
dude like it's a high school girl what
the [ __ ] we look sensitive and stupid no
matter what and it's so funny to like
we've gotten like comments to where it's
just like oh like these influencers like
when it counts they don't stand up it's
like this is what it counts we're
speaking it to the man this [ __ ] 16
year old is the representative of [ __ ]
the man right like in a movie called
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hey just wait it's gonna
be pretty soon yeah if a white person
takes a picture at the Great Wall China
it's gonna be they're happy about the
slavery that built the wall I mean Lena
Dunham just Lena Dunham just came out
and said that's like that sushi is
appropriation like like this College I
used to like this College in America is
serving sushi on campus and she and it's
not authentic enough so it's
appropriation and they had bought me
sandwiches that were served with
ciabatta bread so it's appropriation
it's [ __ ] hilarious that's so [ __ ]
dumb like first of all wishes
you're not Asian at all right shut the
[ __ ] up
I think the most Asian thing about her
is her bowl haircut I think that's the
thing is let us control our own people
because one of the things that did kind
of piss me off when I was reading the
responses to the girl is there was a ton
of white people trying to correct the
situation yeah that's when I was like no
let me [ __ ] take care of my own you
know like let me shut them down like we
don't need you have their group shutting
us or speaking for us yeah well people
are getting even more upset with her
because after the whole backlash she was
tweeting this stuff out right she's
saying I don't see the big deal be
wearing a gorgeous dress I don't
understand everyone's need or desire to
cause so much hey I'm simply showing my
love for a beautiful culture to everyone
causing so much negativity I mean no
disrespect to Chinese culture I'm simply
showing my appreciation
it's a [ __ ] dress and it's beautiful
a lot of people even more than she's
saying like it's just a dress yeah it's
just the dress it is just a dress yeah
she was snapchatting like it's like in
the dress and she's like ching chong
China bomb yeah that's that's what that
is right that that's what these people
are looking for that's what these we
were looking for but not this [ __ ]
I heard worse [ __ ] in third grade so
this one's what are you said this isn't
okay I wouldn't wear traditional Korean
Japanese or any other tradition yeah
it's uncomfortable have you seen a red
dress it's 14 letters that's what she's
saying that there's this person here is
saying I wouldn't wear traditional Irish
or Swedish or Greek
I would why wouldn't you there's a lot
of history being how many [ __ ] toga
parties have you got two in college I'll
put it to you like this right I'm a
really close friend her name is Amen
right she's applicant yeah her mom got
me a dashiki you kept saying yeah I'm
not supposed to say what's a decision
Africa African oh say feels like she got
me that [ __ ] she goes she says like you
guys are now my children so I got it
with the real dashiki so I'm not
supposed to wear that [ __ ] now that's a
[ __ ] dummy you know how [ __ ] up
this [ __ ] is we
in Japan my mom wanted to put just in
the kimono and just felt guilty
she felt weird because of how much she
the pressure and I was like no dude
you're being told by Japanese people to
[ __ ] wear this [ __ ] and in Japan they
want to see white people black people
they want they want them in the kimono
cuz it's like oh they like our culture
they want to [ __ ] dress in it we're
just going to I'm not gonna listen to
Snoop Dog's anymore cuz I love snoop
doggs always been a fan just wait
interesting cuz they're saying that they
keep how itself was appropriating a
different culture because it came from a
different part of China and the other
part of time you think gives a [ __ ]
should interview the Chinese dressmaker
himself and see what he thinks your
auntie the funny [ __ ] though I guarantee
you the people who put these facts out
didn't know about it until they did
research to get exactly oh let me we
competed this why aren't a man at what
rice-a-roni has done to Asian culture
that's what I'm saying every single one
of these people should be lined up for
miles outside of rice-a-roni factories
yeah welcome they're not mad at Panda
Express because they're Asian but then
they didn't even give out authentic
Asian foods you know what I want every
[ __ ] Italian to slap the [ __ ] out of
a Filipino person when they make their
spaghetti into hotdogs to slap the [ __ ]
up with their ketchup [ __ ] spaghetti
and white people should stop to share
other guys with me with the hot dog
carts just going around black guy
catches somebody playing basketball they
just have to share the mention saying
like yeah so what no one can celebrate
Christmas then because that's an E
that's a Western tradition over it's a
North Pole tradition yeah its North Pole
nyan chrisboy yeah only those guys can
come down smack dude wait let's go
Eskimos offensive Mountie right you
can't say now s come on oh my god what
if white people stop going to sushi
restaurants cuz they're like I don't
want to appropriate and all the [ __ ]
sushi chefs like holy [ __ ] where's the
DeKeyser tomorrow then Lena Dunham will
sleep right and then she's all like
thinking she did something right she'll
be walking by knowing that she's not
going in but she'll be having an agent
pick up takeout whatnot leave a tip aha
no more why the people where is a
customer
[Music]